here's what's wrapped up monday here's
what really brian's back from up there
very long
revved up and how about this i'm
drinking my coffee and the way the
flight attendant says this guy goes
snooty guy goes you have to put your
mask on between hips hell yeah how about
i kill every how about i kill you yeah
how about i actually kill you in in
midair oh and i'll kill everybody
there's a three you're ready
oh yeah it's a good time
how about i kill i was i mean you could
have flown
england oh of course i could you know
i do you could to [ __ ]
what i do with that situation i go like
a what and he goes you got to put your
master sips i go no no but yeah i know
well i don't understand what you're
saying and i act like i go yes i know i
will put my mask on i'm just drinking my
coffee between tips i go between what
it's so stupid
you're hoping that when they say it out
loud it sounds as stupid
in their head as what they're saying oh
yeah i wanted to bring up you want them
to repeat themselves podcast with sanjay
gupta and go can you just listen to this
for a second god he let that guy out
well it was just very yeah i like sanjay
gupta forgot a little bit of it did you
did you watch it all the time i liked
what sanjay gupta said he goes i don't
know he goes i don't know hey more of
that please more of i don't know i don't
know i've been okay with saying that my
favorite part is when rogan had him
admit that they shouldn't have lied
about the horse door well that was the
best yeah that wasn't they shouldn't
have done that yeah it was the best the
best that was the best and and uh that's
one of the reasons cnn's
other i mean this gets more readings but
the thing is is yeah what's funny is
remember
sanja
brogan had reached out to him he reached
out to rogan yes and then one of the pr
he was i went to the lion's den because
if you can just change one mind it's
like you went to the lion's gate well he
got eaten a lot because hey it's a home
game yeah it's rogan's home field yeah
and you better come correct daddy yeah
because he's he has you do you think
he's just generally starting these
conversations just hoping that's his
homework oh all the homework and he
crosses his teeth that's all his eyes
and he's right are you the best of them
yes he is and i've i've known that man
26 years if you're getting a debate with
him and it's about what he knows whether
it's if he's if he gets into something
well you don't mean him you know he's
similar i like to argue he likes are you
huh with him though like i'll be going
i'm like this that's not god
i don't know what i'm talking about he's
the only one i'll pull the ejection he's
getting nasty he'll get nasty oh he'll
get me we've had we've had we've had
bad fights at dinner yeah and our our
respective ladies are like oh jesus i'm
going to talk and then 10 minutes later
but like he'll he'll go but if you
argue with him about something that he
really knows like pyramids or i don't
know like [ __ ] bigfoot cars whatever
it might be cars [ __ ] colvin he knows
his [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah and he liked
sanjay and i thought at least sanjay
made they were friends i i think it's i
think having more of those conversations
can move the needle further than
anything yeah fox or msnbc or well one
of the things there's just having the
conversation that
and also rogan's not anti-vaxxed you
guys gotta stop that no but just him
having his perspective going to texas
this guy living in atlanta being a
correspondent for cnn yeah them talking
like this both sides listening to them
that's fair very much yeah well how
about this the fact that if you have had
covet you don't need a vaccine because
you have better immunity
why isn't that being talked about more
and and that was what i think sanjay
gupta was like you know you that you're
you're right and by the way if you take
sometimes you take a double dose of
vaccine after you've had covert you can
have a really bad reaction to the
you're not on a team if you bring that
stuff up you're just it's just you're
just science yeah
you're delivering well he said rogan
said one of the reasons i think i'm
popular is because i i there's no filter
i just tell the truth i just get down to
the truth of it we talked to him like we
would talk to him yes it's not like a
stiff interview you know what i'm saying
it's just changed everything oh my god
it's [ __ ] changed everything it's
probably
yeah i said to him yeah i text him i go
you know i'm proud
because you know like and with all due
respect to a lot of pundits like don
lemon
um
the thing about don lemon is i can
finish his sentences most of the time no
it's nothing creative nothing we haven't
heard predictability i just know where
he's standing by the way but he's also
the people on fox too but i don't i
don't blame either one i don't blame
like
tucker carlson or don lemon because yeah
they're they're a paycheck they're
they're
they're the microphone for whatever and
they have a huge audience that they have
to be loyal huge is
controversial but they it's they're also
like that's their pay that's how they
make their pay you know that's like
they're that's what they're supposed to
do mm-hmm that's right that's exactly
right it's like it's a really cool thing
though there's a lot of there's like
yeah it's part of the american story
nobody else could do that no we're
supposed to tell him and him yeah but
yeah you're right he's
and because he's fair because rogan's
fair you can't pin him down
he can't pin him down he also didn't
bully him either he wasn't like mean
about it he's like hold on don't read up
the stat and you're telling me kids
should get vaccinated right yeah what
are you talking about right he said can
you see how people feel that maybe
there's the same attitude you have it's
the same way young people feel about
getting vaccine very fast there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with that
no it was very respectful it was a great
talk it was very powerful and we need
more of that yeah i got to finish it
well no it took me like hour i listed to
drive i had to go to oc on thursday to
meet with the belt guys their
headquarters out there so i drove down
there listened to it for an hour and a
half then drove back so yeah finished it
yeah me too coming down there driving
back yeah so that was on thursday i had
to drive orange county then friday now
had to drive to brea i would rather
drive to san diego the reason is because
there's so many loopholes it's such a
beast like well it doesn't move some of
the freeways yeah oh almost three hours
on friday
and then again i was like oh saturday's
not even a big deal well nope it was two
and a half on saturday and the way back
we flew down and now we're drop we drove
mark drop mark off and then i was like
we got down in like an hour this is easy
sure enough on the 101 right before we
get to my house bad accent fire truck
goes by told jay what we're not getting
home for a while you guys why you
whenever there's a fire truck they're
going to block all the lines see them
block lanes oh we sat there for an hour
oh yeah so what i do is so i'm i'm i'm
getting a new tesla but i'm getting the
smaller one this time let's go brian
yep let's go now now uh i don't need
that big one i'm getting a smaller one
and the self-drive package is ten extra
thousand dollars worth it
worth it because i go
like that and then i just sit i can just
sit cross-legged and let the car do the
driving you're still in traffic though
it doesn't matter yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't take you out of trouble you know
most modern cars like obviously
like my uh i get the new bronco right
you see that there it's a beautiful car
thank you sir no no you got the top off
the defender selling the defenders were
you thinking about gifting the bronco to
me or no not for you you're not going to
just don't have the right attitude for
it you still have the demeanor or the
attitude but i haven't done your hair in
the wind no no i'm rugged you want long
hair to flap but i'm wearing flannel
cut off
took the top off it rained yesterday so
i was driving like it's cold i suppose
trying to be tough you know and look all
cool
i'm just freezing yeah we drove i had a
convertible bronco and i would get dizzy
on the highway because because they're
smog and i just think
but the thing with the with the new um
with the new um
like cruise control and everything with
the new cruise control see the tops on
there the back i took the top off yeah
see that's what the titties out
yeah now now he's got the titties out
but
now all honesty yeah i mean gun to your
head but be honest
honest
how does it drive amazing compared to
what
it's such a fun car it is because the
top down yeah it's such a fun car and
it's two-door so it's only two-door on
the west coast now be cool so it's only
two door on the west coast the four
doors are out that's only two-door daddy
got it early
so with the top it's just such a fun car
in california like if you're in denver i
bet it's fun we can't have the top like
i'm never gonna put the top on like it
rained last night just took of you know
it's all like waterproof it has a big
computer screen in it really so yeah so
nothing it's like it's ready to get wet
and does it drive
in comparison to that defender which is
they're not giving away they're not
giving it away
how do you compare the drive
so the my only issue with the land rover
is the electronics mess up like i'll
stop to get gas and it just won't turn
on there you go and i called land rover
like i'll just give it time like what
and then 10 minutes goes by and then i
hit and it starts i'm like all right so
you never know when it's going to turn
on that's a big look-wise i think this
car is way better i like the landra
right because english so i [ __ ] with
the english but then
bronco knocked out of the park and so my
plan was because they're going so so
much more over msrp because i got at
msrp because they're going so it's like
once sold for 150 yesterday a two-door
blue one so they're going like you know
double msrp i was like i'm just gonna
get because i ordered a year and a half
ago for the first edition so i was like
oh i'm just gonna get it and then hustle
it and make money but then my guy
dropped off yesterday he's like just
drive it if you want to keep it's just
going to go up in value so let me know
what you want to do with that and
defender i'm like well i'm just going to
sell it yeah drove around the top off me
and jay went to malibu tiger i'm like oh
no no you can't get rid of it i take
some swan like you know that there's a
reason they can't
what's that color be
it's like a grayish i forget what they
think it's a beautiful color it's not
the area 51 it's not getting gray
daddy's lease is up uh in february is
that going to be available
that's why people are paying so much
over because you can't get them
they're good good on ford man yeah
i guess they should have came out a year
ago but because of
roof issues and the covens that like it
was just screwed them so how is um
it's so fun though
it drives really well uh you'll see it
after this yeah the inside's navy only
interested in a two-door it drives very
well you only want the two-door it's
four-door you don't like four doors out
right now the two-door is ridiculous and
drives really well oh so fun it's a
truck it's like a real suv yeah i don't
say truck yeah it should be suv yeah
it's so fun dude yeah um
and and waterproof it's like the thing
you put your dog your shaggy dog yeah i
just took a surfboard yeah i came out
but that's freezing
but i can't refuse to put the top on
couple rifles so i just wiped it down
and then that's what the leather is for
and just [ __ ] threw my [ __ ] in the
back and here we are man now now daddy
uh i and i tried convincing i'm not
going
wants you to have a heart attack um but
i tricked him into chappelle daddy's
doing a tough mudder on sunday 10 miles
10 miles yeah daddy didn't have a trick
knee
daddy
tricked me and he would have done it
no but i liked it
but i i thought about ask you and then
when i saw uh that there's like cold
water and electricity i'm like brian's
gonna die
yeah i would die i would do it i don't
want to be responsible for that i'd do
it and i'd surprise you but he asked me
my kid's doing the mile long uh tough
mudder
because he he wants to do it with his
friend he's like dad me and josh are
going to do it and i was like and i
looked where it's kind of farm like i'm
not going to drive all the way down and
just [ __ ] watch you so i signed up
for it
and and you're gonna i don't like
electricity
a little chilly though huh you're doing
the 10 mile
yeah for the kid yeah how far do you run
usually 10 mile length i've ever had a
big never
i ride you know
depending 20 to 40 miles on my bike
which is kind of you know cardio but
running running no i haven't done
running 10 miles for somebody your size
can be tough on the feet and
i guess dude no he's got those hocus you
like to run i love to run but uh but
remember this isn't 10 miles straight
yeah it's a circle and there's different
stations yeah so you're not running
a mile in a station a mile station sure
it's like there's stations and you're
waiting in line because everyone has to
go through it
i looked it up somewhere i'm like
boy might struggle a little bit what
kind of what kind of uh shoes you
wearing can we look up what the race is
can i see it yeah this is it right there
click on it jen well there's different
ones here
15. i'm doing the 10k tough mudder
all right
so now let me ask you this what uh what
kind of shoes are you wearing i don't
know some jordan ones is that what
you're gonna wear jordan one
no no i don't know no we need to oh
something yeah yeah why i get those
shoes cam haynes sent me that are made
for like mud and [ __ ] those under armour
cam ones oh really yeah they're great
i'll probably wear those
all right hopefully i channel the
camhain's energy there you go he would
[ __ ] destroy it like that i'll be all
right climbing yeah unless it's really
late you can find the water i thrive
here like a polar bear
yep
yeah see obstacles let me see which one
we're gonna struggle with so arctic
enema easy everest bit of a beast the
blackness monster do it is like a
straight wall how 30 foot wall okay it
could be a little
oh this would have kicked my ass the
mutterhorn easy
electrotherapy we'll see might have a
heart attack mud mild i'm all about
getting muddy as [ __ ] look at that
uh keep going the well swung i can't i
can uh this only thing like if i it was
just a well swung i can monkey bar with
the best of them yeah but if i'm tired
i'm 200 every bit of 50 something pounds
that might i might fall into the water
which is okay yeah so it's like ninja
warrior a little bit a little bit wait
what is that electro one castaway b
you're on like a float thing you gotta
pull yourself across oh okay this is not
that easy dude no
what is that everybody doing i don't
understand why they do the electro shock
thing they get hard
well you gotta we got a vertical climb
with water hitting that vertical crime
might be by the way [ __ ] these
[ __ ] are left like shocked
they didn't have to add that electric
shock with water
here's the problem there's a problem 50
people die and it's like well there's
now we're we're we're investigating the
electric short that sent a bunch of
volts but i'm assuming if that big girl
can do it on the right it'll be right
but the thing is is i assume it's like
jellyfish things a little
oh i can all get bit
of short
ten thousand volts hopefully it says
[ __ ] my kid
i don't think he go to the kid once
if he's getting shocked i'm [ __ ]
pulling him out of this thing
no you can't have you can't also be you
asked me last minute i was already going
somewhere
i should i didn't actually last week
it's two weeks away you had to run
through murder hornets gave me a
two-week notice you didn't give me a
two-week notice and that's your last two
dicks
it's not until this sunday you know what
i mean i was already already an obstacle
course of dong's out of town is this the
kids one yeah
no these are not fun all muddy and [ __ ]
i love it yeah
now they have how do you get the mud off
you do you have to have
do they have hoses just we all shower
down
right there
oh so this is the kids i'm definitely
taking my bronco because if you get the
audience
bring a [ __ ] big thing of water texas
hold them tiger dominate most of us let
me see scroll option scroll up
yeah
events right there so uh everest hadoo
berlin wall have buddies funky monkey
who will dominate the monkey bars
texas hold him is that just pulling that
[ __ ] across he'll do fine that's crazy
butter horn he'll be fine
kiss of mud he'll like be great yeah
he'll like that there's no his is just a
mile yeah yeah half mile or a mile oh
yeah he's doing a mile yeah
it'd be fun for him 100 percent his
little friend
and mark's doing it with you right
yeah i sent the group text and mark's
the only one who's like yeah mark harley
yeah yeah mark's doing i want to see how
mark harley does that's a lot of that's
a long way he can run yeah but he's
better than me
we're waiting for an uber and he we
didn't work out that day he goes oh just
run back man take your shirt off i'm
like dude like it was four miles and it
was like 110 out in the humid [ __ ]
ramp yeah
a lot of muscle to feed to your oxygen
your muscles
hey don't
yeah
oh
he's going to break down no no he'll be
fine we'll both guarantee he'll be fine
she's got them [ __ ] friends dude that's
why i invite you what brian we'll do our
own tough mudder yeah all right just you
and i dude do the kids one yeah
marathons tough mudders not for me i
just don't care we can do something else
then we'll figure it out the top mud
would be fun i mean we could all do it
together but
i'm not doing 10 miles it's a long way
it's six miles 10k the shorter
but it's stations remember you're not
running straight six miles yeah
it's not bad no it'll be all right you
just gotta get through each station
yeah
i'd like to see how i do
nfl fans hungry for a big win this
season my broncos suck so i'm starving
for a win we started 3-0 now we're on
three out of the last six whatever
draftking sportsbook an official sports
band partner of the nfl they got you
covered man new customers can bet just
five dollars on any nfl team to win
their game if they do you win two
hundred dollars in free bets winner
winner chicken dinner it's that simple
if sports book isn't available in your
state yet draftkings won't leave you
empty-handed everyone can play for huge
cash prizes all season long with
draftkings daily fantasy sports contest
draftkings has given all new customers a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes with their first deposit
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code fighter bet
just five dollars on any nfl team to win
their game and win 200 in free bets if
they win you win with promo code fighter
this week at draftking sportsbook the
official sports bank partner of the nfl
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit one dollar
wager required one per customer
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
cool call 100 gambler you know how many
people tell me that they don't have time
to work out or they just can't afford a
gym membership
but they're just so many excuses or they
just need some variety in their workouts
or they just want to be able to do
something for 20 minutes 30 minutes 15
minutes sure they don't
i'm talking about peloton but
and peloton the original pelton bike is
now 400 bucks less so now is the perfect
time to get involved now's the time
because 400 less and i love pelton my
profile name on there's thick boy prez
with a z you can see me on there i do 30
minute workouts 45 minutes you got
cardio you got strength classes sure
dude they got yoga on there for your big
ass they got everything man they got
music they got great instructors i love
robin all right they had curated music
for you hip hop contracts collaboration
whatever man we got it all experienced
motivation like never before with
peloton bike now 400 bucks less go to
onepelton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
you still do your peloton sure do yeah
man i promise i did a crossfit workout
and i did all right but i my knee now i
got my is that what you normally do
crossfit no it's weird you're doing
crescendo
after i talk to you i stopped doing
crossfit about i remember seven years
earlier six years ago
we had he was working out we had this
big-time trainer and i go yeah what
should you do crossfit and brennan
looked at me and goes
none of us do crosses
it's it's that's not that's where you're
getting injured yeah and remember when i
did i was doing olympic weightlifting
yeah i was doing olympic weightlifting
with a coach and he's doing like
snatches brennan was like dude i'm just
telling you and i remember
i i lit i did one thing and i could feel
like a ti and i went oh
if i had done a little heavier i'd be
crippled now i could feel it i was like
in your back you got to be you got to be
your technique has to be flawless yeah
and you'll see crossfit like you're
doing so many reps yeah yeah technique
has to be but if you can get crosstalk
it's a great [ __ ] world these people
are all all those [ __ ]
i was doing in venice too and then i did
for like four or five weeks and i was
like man i just here's the problem one
day you're going to be a little tired
and your form is going to lag and you're
going to dead lift for time boom my my
my oh i love crossfit but
here's a place every crossfit they're
always injured my my
impression of every simone guy is you
think i'm big you should see my brother
okay yeah here's my impression of every
crossroads person yeah i'm getting back
into it i got pulled a little ever
now that i think of it i used to know so
many people that would do crossfit now i
don't really know anyone that does it no
it used to be like a huge yeah it used
to be so massive there's people that are
getting the crossfit games and [ __ ]
right it's not espn but those people are
on a different level yeah this is also a
different [ __ ] yes well they would
say no
sure bring up they're not on supplements
bring up the crocodiles just take a look
at take a look at it because they were
all like talking about they don't do any
it's all natural they probably get
tested yeah once again they don't it's a
lot
just kidding you take a look at what
they look like you're like we got to be
a little bit more i mean they're still
monsters yeah they they still are even
if you did all the stairs you'd never be
close to what they are but some of these
some of them are just so thick it's
hilarious fish on earth is fair to say
look at them
oh my god oh my god
yourself they're such athletes
monsters
you don't like when i say athletes
it's tough they're very fit let's put it
there they're in crazy shape yeah and
they're very good at crossfit yes oh
look at them cover chest very
damn and but like i'll see people that
uh go to their insane i'm like skipping
people they're like no i'm not good like
to compete in that you've got to be
crazy like rich fronding in those people
look at that look at that oh my god yeah
that so she was an olympic uh
weightlifter yeah that's natural
but there's still this there's that's
natural she's
right but she's still a freak yeah yeah
they're almost it's not
they're they're monsters there you go
well why oh my god so she was an olympic
woman but why wouldn't you get on [ __ ]
if that like that's what you're you're
you're good
yeah like do as many reps as you can
so that's the concept of crossfit to do
as many reps as yeah that black guy is
our cartoon oh his body they're all
jacked as [ __ ] i know the girls legs are
so big they're thighs and ass yeah it's
a whole different level those those
girls are from iceland the icelandic i
mean there's americans too yes
but
yeah her name is thor's daughter thor's
daughter
um she is a [ __ ] she won yeah i don't
make that face with you she won right
there
yes
i find her very attractive actually i
was just gonna say that that is your
speed man yeah i'm way too light in the
ass huge dude she's a hell of an athlete
she was known i think she had
represented australia in the olympics
for powerlifting or something
i thought crossfit is crossfit's in the
olympics uh
uh there's something so that one there
there
yeah dude you're talking about two both
of them are from iceland a tiny part of
the world where they have these
well they care about grass so you were
you were just doing one you just did one
day
i just did fran i just did a workout
uh-huh yeah there you go now i remember
i used to get nervous for crossfit
because you know you're gonna go through
so much pain oh my god
yeah you're gonna suffer
didn't you get nervous when you were
trained though you had that one trainer
when you were doing mma who would kill
you
tony jeffries no but you make me run
like a [ __ ] miles and miles and
miles
but you got another trainer i feel like
strength and conditioning coach
lauren was tough yeah lauren's tough
lauren's really tough
you alone stuff
oh tell me tell me if you believe this
of course my mexican family does
i uh got home from brea went to bed at
two
and then i woke up at tiger welcome at
seven i woke up and i had a
red
handprint like this over my bicep hot it
was hot
just a red like big handprint and i
thought maybe for me like
fall asleep in the sun coming up that's
what i chalked it up to but then joanna
was like well no it'd be red all around
the handprint because the hand would be
covering the sun
but it's just a red [ __ ] handprint
and she's like that's definitely some
sort of well that's that's called human
satan
oh satan come on doug
so her mom came over with holy water and
sage
and did this weird mexican tradition on
me i love it i was like i'm not buying
any of those
listen dude satan might have shot a
demon through your floorboard and yeah
weird you have a heart it's strange
though right
it's weird yeah
oh dude like a full palm
thinks fingers that are pointing that's
the mark all all over my just nails long
yellow nails yeah like all red and it
was hot dude i know weird huh and then
it went away
yeah once they staged in
yeah for now the holy water it might be
on the inside of your body
yeah maybe i'm haunted i remember that
mike remember i told you my kid all the
stuffed animals he goes can you get this
stuff done he's out of here
why i guess because sometimes they
scratch me yeah what it's like
why you got rid of them immediately i
don't see any scratches he goes no they
scratch me on the inside of my body oh
wow
that's scary and then my my my ex came
in he was a little boy and he goes
there's my other mommy
she goes your other mommy where's the
mommy you were talking to anything like
the sticks on the closet
i could see why your girl and your mom
and her mom believe that they have their
story
know what i'm talking about
they made a movie about it it was a
great popular story oh they made a movie
about it mexican story la la la rona la
llorona
the lady with the unibrow is interesting
oh they made a movie out of it look at
that picture down there though that's
the lady that grabbed my [ __ ] arm
right there that's who grabbed your arm
she grabbed my arm so it's probably her
oh that's scary dude i was watching uh
i'm super into ghost adventures right
now it's pretty phenomenal but um
i was watching this uh not not first 48
it was more than that where they dive
into like crime stories
i could i could not go to bed i saw it
finished because we were talking about
prison yeah dude so a true story
this uh
man
and uh girl
go off to the military they're both
stationed in north korea they get
married but then they're stationed at
different stations
they come back from being stationed i
forget where it's at and they live in
like a trailer park whatever he gets he
he goes out he go he he goes to get food
for his wife and they have a kid
together he goes get food he gets gunned
down shot sometimes shot in the back of
the head trap shut the [ __ ] up dies
they have the police footage the body
cam of them walking up and the the wife
balling trying to get into the ambulance
balling like wow how the [ __ ] how does
happen going nuts and the dad's there
and he's like my son's a good boy this
doesn't make sense blah blah and he's a
big dude with dreads big black guy
big dude and he's like this doesn't make
sense blah blah blah he's furious he's
like who the [ __ ] would do this so the
cops uh are looking in the case like we
think it was a mistaken identity and
they thought he was a gang member so
they investigate that they find nothing
like man something has to be going on
here they talked to the girlfriend
so they have the dad they asked that go
hey can you come down with the wife
and uh we need some question for you he
goes yeah sure no problem she's like
yeah of course whatever it takes
the dad gets them they have this all on
camera the dad gets there and they go
we're gonna be a while once you go home
and he's like what the [ __ ] that's like
what because the wife was staying with
the family the whole time
saying that crying like and they were
you know trying to consult her and take
care of her so the dad goes what the
[ __ ] they go we're gonna be well why
don't you go ahead and go home so they
bring in the best like uh investigator
in all the land they bring him in he's
the number one guy that does the lie
detector test
she fails the lie detector which happens
and even admits he goes sometimes soft
but she lied about a few things
so he keeps talking
she's there for seven hours she got
there at 11. she's there for seven hours
finally she's like all right
what happened is
i was dating another man it's not what
it seems i was dating a i started dating
another soldier because he would listen
to me started dating him
and uh he want to take care of the
problem and so when uh he was like
drove down from like memphis to like
texas wherever it's at drove down there
and the kid went out at night and he
would uh follow him in his car
but i guess there was he was going to do
it at night club but there's too many
witnesses so he waited so she was like
well the right time would come just stay
close
so uh
dude so when he went to get food she
texted her side piece he's going to get
food so he comes up shoots them right
shoots him they solve all this the girls
behind all of it because he had a
insurance plan that where she would get
like five hundred thousand dollars what
a piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] right this
is what's crazy
that that this is all on camera the dad
goes into the prison because he gets
life the girl gets life they're both
[ __ ] yeah
the kid's [ __ ] right so the dad goes
into to talk to him because you want to
talk to the killer of his son he's
sitting down he's super mild-mannered
like big dude dreads he's sitting there
and uh the they're talking about in the
sun and the killer's like i want you to
know man it was her plan like she she
won the the 500k
i was just caught up in it i apologize
she never got like this one dad's like
no i get it man i get it you're strapped
for cash i get why you would do this
yeah he's like can you ever forgive me
and the dad he just doesn't answer but
he's cool i'm like why the [ __ ] being
so cool
and then the then the killer goes
you look like you want to kill me right
now because i don't want to kill you he
was i don't know her name's like tiffany
he was i don't know if did tiffany ever
tell you what i what i used to do and
what i'm involved with and you see the
guy's like demeanor change he goes no he
goes
i got a lot of friends where you're at a
lot of friends and he goes and you meet
a lot of friends
and he goes you can see his face turns
white he's a black dude his face he's
like mix he turns white and he goes what
do you what is that threadios saying you
meet a lot of friends in there
you meet a lot of you just give him you
meet a lot of friends and he goes have a
good have a good night hangs up the
phone walks off then you interview the
dad at his house like days later
and they go uh he got lives are you
happy with that he goes yeah that's fine
he won't make it two years
and then just end it
i was like holy [ __ ] i could not get
enough of it yeah he has a lot of
friends in there my man because i know
she told you the crowd i used to run
with but they're all in there and you're
making a lot of friends and kept going
what semming is you're making a lot of
friends
i was like holy [ __ ] you're [ __ ] up
yeah they're like well they gave him
life isn't that ha aren't you happy with
that he goes oh that's fine he won't
make it two years
didn't give a [ __ ] dude
well here you can holy because you you
and i know what it's like his son also
ran with that same crowd
yeah
yeah you know what exactly and then they
and it's like they're they dominate that
wherever whatever prison he was in there
they're just everywhere yeah you're not
gonna well you said his son ran with
that crowd too yeah he's like have a
good have a good night hang up the phone
oh my god can you imagine that ruthless
tear that [ __ ] which obviously he
deserves too yeah well you're never
gonna
you and i have a son so you don't even
know how much you love that kid like
it's it's beyonce oh my god he's [ __ ]
kidding me you just you don't care
anymore about anything i don't want
peace no
you got to do something like that i
don't want but this dad was so mild
manner in control i'm like how's he not
going crazy the murder is literally two
inches away from through this because he
oh he's just listening he's like
i want you in the ground yeah yeah
that's you're you're on this on the
process you want him in the ground
there's no other alternative yeah in the
ground but dude the way this that that
the wife was like when the kid was shot
like on the body cam i'm like he was
like freaking out crying and he was like
she's a good actor man she's like she's
a good actor a she had no remorse either
like they were like do you want to say
anything to them she's like
sociopath yeah that's what he said he
was like it's crazy because she she's
like my daughter she stayed with this
whole time like she would give her how
could she do that too yeah
living with people dude some people just
and they had no child together
oh my god what a [ __ ] monster piece
of [ __ ] you know there there are people
like that uh sam giancana you know the
guy who was who ran the entire chicago
mob what during kennedy's
presidency and and was credited joe
kennedy went to sam giancana and said or
to that outfit and said we need the
unions in these two states and g and
conor would just call and be like hey
everybody's voting for [ __ ] jack
kennedy because he's gonna because he is
gonna end up doing us a favor he'll get
somebody at the department of justice
the d.a who won't put as much pressure
on so so just so you so like both
kennedy's died jack and john died right
and most of it's
john is the same as jackson john and
bobby yeah bobby that's right bobby
kennedy and jack and his son in the war
jfk so a lot of people contribute
they're like especially bobby just
killed in la actually yeah by mafia and
then jfk they think same thing mafia
related with assassination because
the the rumor but there's also evidence
for it is they got elected through the
power and ties to the mafia
then once they got in office they
started implementing rules that [ __ ]
them off know well
especially in new orleans bobby kennedy
was was was he was literally yeah he was
the main guy he he was he was on an
anti-mafia crusade in fact giancana said
i [ __ ] we got this guy elected
thinking that we'd get we were gonna
they're meeting halfway bobby kennedy
was the officer he went after him went
after him you could see them and that
that's awesome that's also when john f k
uh died yeah bobby kenny dipped out yeah
he didn't he because they're like hey
man if you go this route and brought us
out we have videos and pictures and
audio of your brother doing some
hallucinations
we'll ruin his entire reputation and
then we're going to come after you but
bobby got god right yeah he was like oh
i'm out and then he kind of stepped back
in and then [ __ ] got shot in la i
mean dude oh uh he was doing like a like
a press conference or whatever he was
out here for something but yeah they got
him she and connor gene connor was like
you see bobby kennedy interview him and
he's up there he's running he's running
he runs the entire chicago mob
yeah ruthless he would ha he'd torture
people and want to know what the last
thing they said was he'd be like what
was the last thing they said he'd be
like
like and so when bobby kennedy is
interviewing him he'd go like this he'd
go so you run uh you run the biggest
outfit crime off and he like this he
goes
i'm sorry i got to take the fifth
because i'm afraid i'll incriminate
myself he kept saying that bobby kennedy
i got to see this kennedy what's his
name bobby kennedy goes you just keep
giggling like a little girl is that what
you're gonna do this whole time and he
goes i just i gotta just please the
kenny's got after him though yeah like
to their defense they got after him
that's why they both know but also that
i'll give you this book it's [ __ ]
fascinating yeah yeah because when they
uncover like all those the when they
looked into the jfk assassination and
bobby's the ties to the mafia is in
texas in dallas and new orleans is
insane dude so the guy that claimed to
have shot kennedy he was just
regular dude just yeah
yeah
he was that he had spent
time in cuba whether he did or not
jackie had ties jack ruby who shot
lehigh
he had ties them off so he had super
tight
club that i went to but then also there
was like a uh speakeasy where all the
mafia politicians and cops hung out
oh dallas yeah all of them hung out
there yeah
oh yeah does that place still exist i
don't think social media
shot was killed he got extradited back
to the united states i think he was
coming back he was in chicago i think he
was in italy or something and they they
actually got back he got it yeah and and
then uh in 1975 in his home
he just got
shot i see what he looks like he never
found him 40 years later what's his name
oswald is he was he lived in new orleans
he lived in new orleans
and the the all these guys like they
would kick him they would go to new
orleans to shut down the mafia yeah and
lee harvey oswald spent time like it's
it's it's well jeans
and jack kennedy had the same mistress
too yeah they were having sex at the
same time so the kennedy's so you're
saying the kennedys called him up in
chicago and was like you know mafia
helped them
frank sinatra was was around all those
guys
he was having sex with her but he was
also having sex with uh who is the other
woman that one down there jesus christ
how could you not this guy looks
dangerous
that's right tonight
no no no no no no no
phyllis mcguire i think that's her
yep he died at 89.
yeah phyllis mcguire i think that was
her she was having she was with j jack
kennedy and sam g and kind of dated both
of them
john kennedy yeah
damn that was good jfk stuff yeah
such a it's such a wild they were doing
a
lot
it's the best thing to read up yeah like
i'm not a big conspiracy guy but that is
fantastic there's no yeah the mob had to
be involved in a lot of yeah it's so
easy
you said jack jack
how did jack ruby just shoot lee harvey
oswald then he died of cancer no no jack
jack hold up jack ruby not only got
access inside the police department when
they're bringing lee harvey up to shoot
him yeah but then also when he went to
prison he he was like i have some things
to say like if you guys like me i get
some things say and he dies of
and then they wouldn't let them talk
anymore they don't want to do press
conference they wouldn't let them talk
and then dies of cancer yeah
yeah dude but he should
he shot harvey oswald before he could
say anything isn't that correct and
here's the interesting amount of oh when
lee
was walking down he was cuffed
and lee harvey oswald
never confessed to the he always went i
didn't do this like i'm being set up i
did not do never on record is he
confessing but
but i i don't know i guess some of you
here's why why lee harvey why hasn't
it's an easy scapegoat well i think he
probably did it because jack ruby killed
him but what would you say b
and the whole thing was unbelievable
they pulled it off
it's great
the mafia back then was so powerful maya
lansky sam giancana they could shut down
the whole thing well that's why bobby
was going after him yeah yeah they could
call make one phone call and the whole
port was shut down they had the fulton
fish market yeah
everything they had their hands involved
you didn't do any there was no garbage
there was no construction there was no
fish mongering and the union's called
everything that's why homeboy went
missing yes um
from the i with the irish uh the
irishman uh
no no no no no no no who's the guy that
went uh
uh jimmy jimmy hoffa
he was the president of the union so he
was the president of you and
still to this day he went because he was
so involved in mafia yeah he went away
for seven years for racketeering
and then came back and tried taking back
over the union with just went and then
all of a sudden just one minute but the
guy's back
that's so [ __ ]
the guys back then the old school dudes
yes
discipline him but not just sammy the
bull there was a guy who was his
underboss
um no no uh
actually it's the uh castellano bring up
i think it was castellano's underboss
castellanos underboss yeah
what about assassinated by john kennedy
at spark steakhouse
um
yeah and and uh just take a look at what
he looks like now is that well he got
shot in the steakhouse thomas baloti
maybe
yeah that was his owner boss he was such
a bad guy so he got those guys but
he's never dealt with drugs right they
dealt with prostitution gambling yeah
all that they refused to deal with drugs
yeah like okay like that was like the
rule yeah when they got back when they
got into drugs it became a hold up
that's when the problems came that's
right and the jewish mafia refused to
get involved in drugs and the big
difference in jewish mafia and the
italian mafia was the jewish mafia their
kids their kids didn't come doctors and
lawyers yeah they didn't go into the
business they were like no we're doing
it so we can pay for you guys get
education
because the italian mafia the kid would
become is that
that picture of his body yeah
where is it at in new york or new york
now they could now john gotti ordered
the hit on him so he could take over the
family yeah
again you know family
i remember that i think i was in new
york when that happened crazy
yeah [ __ ] ninja oh you you were born
when that happened oh yeah i was there
47 when that happened
on tv
that's right
i was involved he was like can you
believe what i was involved in just
watching the tv did you ever see the
video of uh john gotti with his grandson
when he goes to visit his grandpa in uh
in prison because he got life right yeah
yeah he's [ __ ] out of throw cancer
yeah teflon don but and he his problem
is he got two feet he want to be a
celebrity he got too famous then all the
heat was on him wait who uh john gotti
john got two families but there's an
interview of his grandson who's a
fighter now but he goes into um
he goes in to tell him he wants to be a
basketball player dude
he john got such a dick to him yeah
because you're not what are you talking
about you're not a [ __ ] basketball
player what are you talking about let me
be a basketball player that's [ __ ]
stupid that's right he's like you know
what takes me about and just tears into
him yeah but the kids ate two oh he's
eight he's like eight or nine oh and and
then and then he and then the kid goes
no that's what i want to do here it is
that you might go to school and become a
lawyer
no daddy he is going to become a lawyer
really no i'm not going to be a
basketball player
[Music]
let me tell you something he's being
smart today
let me tell you something about
basketball players and baseball players
to be to be good basketball player or
baseball player choice of role you got
to be a good liar a good low life
takes a lot of drugs
you gotta take steroids you must take
steroids
[Music]
you get an ass kicker for me i ain't
your father
[Music]
[ __ ]
right now i got a million people who if
they could come here to see me now they
will cry just to be able to be here to
see me
so you ain't doing me no favor coming to
see me or talking says to me
you say that for your father you're sick
you say that says for me i put my foot
up your ass you hear me
don't you look at me later
you know i'm serious in cancer boy
the truth of the matter with you guys
you just broke out damn right
there's people that don't even have a
goddamn good man wouldn't get the
answers you gave just me
you can look as [ __ ] as you want to look
now get that phone to help and get the
hell out of here oh
jesus he's all crying he's in a suit too
a little soup
[ __ ] with me
that [ __ ] comes from your [ __ ] mother
not from me
that kid's all probably not gonna see
grandpa anymore
[Music]
now he feels bad see now he's backing up
because he's got that flashlight
what a nice guy he was huh wow imagine
your grandpatent jesus christ man
that's what um have you ever seen that
nuts he went on to become an mma fighter
he did yeah he's pretty good that kid
yeah he was fighting bellator oh [ __ ]
good friends
he's like all right grandpa i'll show
you yeah
that's a tough thing that's tough to
have uh your grammar remember but his
dad took over the family he went to
prison for it for a long time that's
right i think sammy the pool wasn't have
you ever seen oh [ __ ] look at this kid
that's awesome
have you ever seen is this you he's in
the ufc now no i think that's probably
fight pass stuff oh have you ever seen
when uh john gotti junior comes to tell
his dad that he doesn't want to be in
the business no dude let me see that no
that's too long that that's gonna take
20 minutes i'll do a recap i'll do the
cliff nose for you so he comes in and
he's sitting down his dad's like you
don't [ __ ] snitch that's why i'm in
here you don't [ __ ] snitch he's like
no i get it dead and he can tell he
wants to tell him he's really nervous
and but they show him now you know he's
like 50 something years old now he's
like a normal dude like nice guy dude he
didn't want to be in the business he's
like we're just all going to end up here
man i have kids like i don't want to do
this no i've already got paints for
eight years man so the the prosecutors
kept trying to make an example at him
keep keep running through trials he's
like i'm sick of this man i'm missing my
kids like this isn't the life for me
because i don't want to do it dude
his dad [ __ ] tears him an [ __ ] and
he's gonna die he has like cancer he's
like a month to live yeah tears into him
really he's like you piece of [ __ ] what
you [ __ ] rat he's like you do not rat
you don't make a deal they're gonna come
no matter if you make a deal or not
they're gonna [ __ ] come after you
he's like either way i end up in here
man i don't want this life no and just
the cojones it took for him
to tell his dad like i don't want to i
don't want to stop man he said i had
kids this isn't a lie no no you grow up
and you go what where is it well you
know how it's going to end
we know how it's going to end up either
dead or in jail you're also not flying
under the radar like the the the fbi and
the prosecution's all over it's like we
have friends who deal drugs and we have
a friend who want to get back out here
dude do you think you're smarter than
the you know those guys that graduate
harvard that go on to go to the fbi yeah
you don't have a college education you
think you're going to outsmart those
people
with the us government and a lot of
people who work together as a team so
you can say what you want about the
government obviously they make a lot of
mistakes but when it comes to that stuff
the fbi the smartest of the smart yeah
yeah they're gonna get you they're gonna
get you
you didn't go down that rabbit hole the
fbi like edgar hoover and stuff like gay
man oh yeah oh really oh dressed up
dressed up in uh dresses yeah gay man
you know that starred the fbi that's
what's called a heartfelt game no
how dare you no no by the way i saw i
was like guys guy
when i was when i was in i saw the
strangest thing in this weekend i'm at
the i'm staying at the waterfront
marriott and a guy
a thick asian dude had to have had some
samoan in him i mean really wide
and he had uh i just saw shoulders but
his hair looked super moosed his hair
was like too much slick a little bit i
was like and it was kind of falling to
one side and i was like
i mean that's that's
that doesn't that's yeah it's it's uh
but he goes uh
he cut we kind of he was there and i we
kind of i had to move out of the way
from the door and he went like this i
went like that in baltimore yeah and he
goes and he goes sorry bro sorry bro and
i go oh no
and i look down and he's got a jean
skirt on
and
these high heels
it was so interesting so he was a dude
clearly a very thick guy
who decided to throw on a tight
jean skirt and something and everybody's
gonna say [ __ ] to him big big
[ __ ] no one's gonna say very big
dude very big it was so interesting and
he didn't look good in it it was like
that no no i bet that's pretty freeing
tighter than that and way more like
you're doing that's dangle out in the
air
and super uh dude i'm one what did you
say don't scottish uh men wear guilt
yeah this is different you know yeah
like that guy's high heels on that's
actually that's photoshopped oh it's
photoshopped oh that guy is short dress
ass cheeks out the back that guy's
definitely looking dude i'm one bad
break away from wearing a [ __ ] skirt
like that
that could be that's gonna be me when
i'm 60.
he has some legs on him yeah deontay
wilder has there's a picture of him with
the shirt off and it looks like he's
wearing a kind of a longer skirt he
could pull it off he could he could 100
pull off a sarong we call that a sarong
in indonesia that's tough you wrap it
like a towel but it's like
yeah that's cool yeah but it goes all
the way if you wear it right that's cool
come out like that yes he can pull that
[ __ ] off well he has jeans on so yeah
yeah but that's just a long shirt is it
but pete davidson go to pete davidson at
a fashion show where he wears straight
so does machine gun kelly was in chat
yeah those guys becoming like a thing i
think with fashion they're just like
dude we can't only make we can only make
so many [ __ ] pants what should we do
right there there you go that's a new
thing that works though with him like
he's just yeah talking
about your tall weird guy like it works
and i don't assume he's gay like when he
if he wears a dress no i like pete
davidson
yeah machine gun kelly's worn it yeah i
feel like he can do anything like that
guys i guess [ __ ] tall i saw him the
other day off intro and he's so tall
he's like 6'5 right yeah he's tall and
scary man real skinny he just has that
but that he's an ectomorph where i'm
sure you can cheat one of the [ __ ] he
wants yeah
yeah he is he's a tall he's a good
looking dude hey marilyn manson been
wearing skirts facts
the thing is about uh machine gun kelly
ever since he's talking [ __ ] to slip
night he's getting booed at like every
concert really yeah
he almost got a fight at the last one
for real because it's not his concert
he's he's he's doing like these
festivals okay where they're slipknot
fans
oh really so it'd be like
it'd be like me talking [ __ ] to
let's say kevin hart right i never would
but it's like me talking [ __ ] to kevin
hart and then doing like the moon tower
festival and he's there so he's on there
and then he's like a big thing of the
big yeah it's like slipknot
wow
and the slipknot have you seen what went
down with slipknot why they're they're
mad at them so yeah yeah it was the you
know trash barker's the connection yeah
so travis parker's the middle man
and then he produced uh uh
kelly's album and he wanted the elite
corey
cory taylor corey taylor to do a verse
on uh his thing right and so uh he
reached out to corey taylor and corey
taylor sent a verse machine gully want
to change all of it he's like one do all
this stuff and corey taylor for slipping
that's a big deal he's a really good
he's like oh i'm good man i i don't like
if you're gonna [ __ ] with myself i'm
good and just left at that and then uh
he said something he said a little bit
more he was like he goes but if you want
me to help you find
a singer that could you know that you
he's being cool yeah he was being cool
travis yeah yeah he yeah he has because
he posted the email yeah then in an
interview he was like
he's saying something like guys that
fail in one lane then come over to rock
you know and that guy knows who i'm
talking about he's referring to machine
gun kelly the machine gun kelly got on
stage
i'm not 50 were in a [ __ ] mask hey
they've been killing those mess since 99
and then it's just been all right it's
just been on yeah what what is um what
machine gun kelly is a rapper but he was
a rocker no no
he obviously started off rap and then
went to rock it's actually but he always
played guitar though well when he first
like all his underground [ __ ] like he
always had that like rock undertone
but he mainly like he had a way of
incorporating the rock into the rap so
like he was trying to start this new but
he was he was like one of those fast
rappers right yeah yeah like a tech nine
yeah he has a
a song called uh 100 100 words a minute
where he it's literally like the
eminem and uh rap god where he's just
spitting really fast
i like his music i know it's for young
kids i don't give a [ __ ] she's actually
on tour with him right now who is gianni
oh well yeah he's at uh the red rocks
with him tonight that's cool oh [ __ ]
it's been waiting why are you wearing a
white socks at it's crooked what's going
on there what do you mean crooked it was
crooked
but you're from boston
you like the socks or the yeah i mean
the white socks sometimes you gotta
represent i just like the hat he's like
boston you're from i'm from rhode island
oh yeah but you brought this box yeah
right
my sports scene because you said that's
closer you're cl the side you grew up on
is it literally takes me 45 minutes to
get to like logan like logan
international like downtown boston for
my house and i'm on the other side of it
right now i wore uh just because i was
wearing all blue so the only hat had to
match it it was like dark blue was a
huge smash was that and i forgot it's
the playoffs and the astros and dodgers
[ __ ] hate each other i worked to
breath and the match like what because i
wear my hat forward before i get on
stage and i put it backwards on stage i
bought what do you what no no no what
are you doing what he was dude we're in
the playoffs who's done players he was
dodging okay so he goes you can't wear
[ __ ] houston's out they're gonna kill
you out there he was put it backwards so
he didn't put it backwards chill dude
it's not a big deal matches the outfit
and then the next day i come and in the
green room he's like here he popped me a
brand new brought him a brand new like
where's this dude there was a lot of
dodgers fans in the audience they were
they were rocking the gear like that's
when you get real fans yeah down that in
that area like they come from the
midland empire and stuff like that
they're like are they inland they were
like it was a lot of them
he's like dude give a [ __ ] don't wear
that
i did not wear it because i'm trying to
help you out yeah it's just a style
thing you see i don't give a [ __ ] why
you're wearing it don't wear houston
astros on stage tonight yeah that's like
that's like a pittsburgh don't don't
wear the opposing colors and pins
there's certain places you can't yeah
they're just so difficult i don't wear
like bears you're in the playoffs i
swear to god you look out there and it's
like everybody's in a steelers jersey
i'm like i get that it's saturday guys
can we calm down although i hear in
europe it's super intense when it comes
to like soccer um oh it's a religion
yeah oh no i heard it's like patty
pembleton got kicked out because he was
cheering for the other team oh dude they
kicked him out of the stadium because
you're not you know uh patty the the new
i don't know because they don't want to
they don't want to start right now
yeah so you know you can't cheer for the
other team otherwise you get kicked out
dude and his team was like people were
getting killed winning like nothing and
he was going nuts and they're like
in ireland in ireland and england they
police have a list of people that are
not allowed to attend yeah
just to attend the soccer games because
it's thuggery it's fantastic gangs would
show up and do crazy [ __ ] yeah it's
fantastic yeah they get that they go
that hard
knife knife crime
you know chappelle and jay are going to
england next year yeah we're going to
boy we're going to yeah yeah we're going
liam gallagher yeah yeah we're going to
uh see him at net worth great me and jay
you guys gonna high five and be like i
can't believe we're seeing liam going
i'm just asking
i'm asking are you guys going to high
five now
yeah we're going to have a great time
there could be anybody there could be a
better person to go with i don't know
but he's like he goes what all do you
want to see i was like
i would like to go back because i've
been watching the crown yeah go on a
tour of the
palace and show you here
buddy told me his story my body told me
i'm watching paul mccartney i'm sitting
there watching paul mccartney sing i
want to hold your hand and i was just
[ __ ] crying i'm just crying and i was
like man
you and i
come from different units
i
i live life close to the bone and i wear
things hard that's why he lives life
happening
i've had these were bought for me on my
50th birthday yup i remember that they
they were my buddy goes you under
designer sneakers my buddy i go i don't
know what that means he goes i'm sending
you some and i got these in the mail
those are like it's really expensive 600
bucks or something right yeah [ __ ]
they you know i don't know yeah they're
crazy but then they seem like i'm
wearing baseballs somebody stretched out
a baseball like their low end
uh ones are just are super they're
they're handmade they don't make super
super comfortable yeah
[ __ ] golden super
yeah you can find some jordan's cheaper
than that for sure all right jim what do
you got dude
all righty chin came to the breast show
with little brows
fast lane it was a fun fun time man i
love good shows huh
great yeah
which is a thursday friday
i'm just gonna get ready yeah
saturday we have uh oh
god bless you
christian uh came christian is learning
the comedy game right because there's
you know guys invite their friends and
stuff
oh god christian learned two valuable
lessons what kind of lessons yeah very
valuable so he brought some super fan
back to the room which
he brings his kid back and the kid
he has a young kid podcaster has so much
energy so much but it's just like
everyone's like jesus christ dude so
then david says something they would
lose they said because his hair was all
up he said you look like you stuck on a
roller coaster
because he goes oh i look like a mexican
mexican justin bieber i said the [ __ ]
you do yeah because he asked for it he's
like i was like the [ __ ] you do so david
took a jab and then we just it was david
just like
so you look like a mexican johnny bro
oh i see you guys later
mistake number one for christian number
two he's trying to help out we had a
team he's great i wish he's on the road
all the time that's the number two
number two there's a bunch of people in
the room you know how it works in the
green room they only provide
alcoholic beverages to the to the people
performing and then maybe like if your
your brother's there who deals with
business but the rest of people they
don't cover he go the room's packed i
mean everyone's there you know how my
green rooms are i like being around
people it's packed can i get anybody a
drink
offers it
i'll take this i'm like christian let me
talk to you real quick
this first round that's fine it's on me
he's like well i'm like yeah if they're
not with me
it's not included on the building he's
like ah [ __ ] and what happened that dude
was wearing drinks all night long oh boy
now you know dude
he is a great
[ __ ] guy and he's very forgiving
because if you've done that
to rokin oh god you you're fired well
first of all it wouldn't happen nobody
would be in the room yeah but
well i always say that it's like justin
made a mistake in denver
this guy comes they go hey do you guys
have this blah blah blah photographer
here i go not enough photographer justin
goes oh no i did he's my opener he was i
hired my own photographer you did what
he goes yeah this guy dma i have my own
photograph just let me talk to you when
you're headlining you can have any
photography you want i don't think if i
wear dresses on stage
you're the opener yeah so i don't want
somebody that i don't know taking
pictures i don't trust that and kyle was
already there yeah the promise and i
have my ability well that's why i told
him i go and i go just so you understand
because you're in the game that long
just so you understand i've had it
happen where when i first started out
guys would have to take pictures and i
post a picture like you owe me five
thousand dollars you
use my art like what
yeah i'm like i'm telling you the reason
why i'm so strict with this stuff
because i've learned the hard way dude
yeah i've had i've had openers that
think it's cool to bring back a bunch of
professional girls you know girls that
are like covered in glitter and
obviously don't have a profession and
you go that cannot be in this you gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here no we i mean
we're gonna take you like in the airbnb
i don't give a [ __ ] who you i mean kyle
if you met a nice girl you could bring
it better than that there's no girls
allowed airbnb there's no i don't need
your family nowadays nowadays it's just
too much but it's also what are you
doing dude yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah
hey christian learned though yeah
everybody learns you've got he's good
he's super helpful we all learn that way
there's no there's no is there any other
way is there any other way to learn
besides the hard way yeah i guess you
really listen but for the most part you
gotta you gotta try it you know you
gotta touch the plate see if it's hot
yeah sometimes but but i always tell him
i i didn't tell chris unless you just
did he'd be fired if he worked for rogan
but also justin time like if you were
any other headliner you would be out of
a job he's like really i'm like dude
are your pants connected to your shoes
no no no you
me no no uh oh okay okay okay
oh i thought they were connected
all right that's chin came with his
young cousin some dime piece girl and
his girl both good looking cousins like
very good looking
the uh this other they're related kyle
and
christian yeah the girl was diamond yeah
she was shy though she's very shy and
you know my girl finally came and her
mom came there and i set where i go
super hard oh it was amazing you haven't
seen my city i go super hard on her so i
go
because all of tiger's uh friends uh
parents came too so i sent a group text
before i went on segment i need you guys
know one thing i go hard in the paint on
on joanna and her mom it's just jokes
now this is serious please don't judge
me
vagina loved it her mom was cool of
course
they had a great time yeah it's so much
fun to [ __ ] around yeah i think it's not
i was it's not serious i wrote stuff on
my kids that
is killing and it's kind of mean but
it's also kind of true what do you do
yeah it's kind of funny all right jim
what do you got all right here we go
so vanessa bryant is currently in a
lawsuit with
i could let's do it all right cool
i knew that was gonna happen all i'm
gonna say is this my friend who is
very deep in cryptocurrency sure
whatever you do
just buy or hold on to some bitcoin and
i promise you in 10 years you'll be a
very happy person well dude no too many
smart people who are involved in this
well dude you got a credit card right
yeah what if i chose the credit card
where you earn bitcoin instead dude dude
tell me more dude earn bitcoin instead
with block fi has the world's first
bitcoin rewards credit card that lets
you earn unlimited 1.5 in bitcoin on all
qualifying purchases wait so if i'm a
crypto pro or a total beginner i can do
this yeah man wish you got into bitcoin
a lot sooner brian well has the world's
first bitcoin rewards credit card so you
can earn bitcoin on all qualifying
purchases i keep telling you that man
introducing the block 5 rewards visa
card signature card it's the easiest way
to get bitcoin by just making everyday
purchases you can so you can grow your
bit coin portfolio when you buy
groceries pay your bills fill up the gas
whatever dude just normal stuff you're
paying on your credit card now you're
earning bitcoin block fi is the leader
in crypto and it was named forbes
fintech 50 list in 2021. right now
finally kid listeners and viewers can
get a bonuses 25 bucks in crypto after
you make your first purchase with a
credit card when you sign up at
blockfi.com
fighter that is 25 buckaroos and crypto
deposit right into your freaking account
after you make your first purchase but
you have to use blockfy.com fighter
start earning bitcoin back on all your
qualifying purchases today blockfy.com
fighter not all will be eligible
geographic regulatory and underwriting
restrictions supply fees and terms of
subject to change additional terms of
service at blockfight.com blackfy is a
financial technology company banking
services provided by evolve bank and
trust remember member fdic or rember or
remember hey b uh you need some car
parts right yes i do we do we all need
park carpet
everybody has a car things break down
and i but you know what it's so
expensive yeah dude dude why would you
choose spend 30 50 100 for the exact
same auto parts at a chain store or a
new car dealership because that's all i
have that's the only one i have bro i'm
here to help with rockauto.com you will
save bank bro
rockauto.com yeah rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto part
customers online for 20 years
they have everything from engine control
modules brake parts tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's a classic a
new car fusey clicks boom shows up at
your door best part
prices at rocket.com are always reliable
low and the same for professionals
do-it-yourselfers why spend up to twice
as much for the same parts so i just go
to
rockauto.com and see all the parts that
bail available for a car or a truck you
just do what do they do just write
fighter in the how did you hear about us
box that they know that that's right b
it's like you're reading this oh amazing
selection reliably low prices all parts
your car will ever need rockauto.com
right fighter in the how did you hear us
about us box all right first one
so vanessa bro
oh that's a dude
she is beautiful yes gorgeous vanessa
bryant is currently in the middle of a
lawsuit with l.a county because shortly
after the plane incident with kobe and
gianna
there were photos of their bodies that
were leaked
from people who were working with police
forces right yeah the photos were leaked
and those officers i believe got fired
but she's suing l.a county for it and
they're making her undergo a psychiatric
test to make sure that the reason why
she was under emotional distress was
from the photos being leaked but they're
trying to say it's just from the crash
not from the photos being leaked well
the la district is going to go through
whatever it takes
yeah but i i have to say that uh those
that is disgraceful
yeah it's your [ __ ] leak a 13 year
old
you know they need all the pages and
like text each other like it's that's
[ __ ] insane
[ __ ] you have some respect
a-holes
all right and next six nine spotify
playlist got hacked and the photo that
was originally on his spotify playlist
was changed to a picture of someone's
dick we have no idea whose deck it is
yeah
it was a black dick if it's them
or someone who is racially ambiguous it
was not takashi's no and
that ended up getting taken down and
later it was changed into a photo of him
animal morphing into a rat and the only
song that was on his playlist was a
trippy red song so trippy red fans
hacked the spotify uh we don't know if
it's a trippy red fan
it's just somebody who hates six nine
because him and trippy red aren't cool
and we can't see that big dick
no they took it down they took it down
yeah i couldn't find it i was the person
that keeps hacking six nights
that's really fun these are great that's
really funny what else you got jen
so daniel craig made some headlines
because he said in an interview recently
that he likes going to gay bars and he's
been going to gay bars for a good
portion of his life because he says that
he doesn't get in as many bar fights
when he goes to a gay bar that's a gay
man
well britain britain i guess it's easy
to get in fights if you're just an actor
and people pick fights because they get
drunk but oh okay
i don't think that's a britain thing i
mean that's anywhere if any celebrity
goes to any bar
maybe someone's going to [ __ ] is it that
big of a problem never seen it nah i
don't i mean you like to hang out gay
bars
i mean
it's all good tank abbott said that once
he said he used to go to gay bars just
so he didn't get it really yeah
just so he didn't get fights that was
also in the early 90s i think james
bond's fine
i think also do you need to drink that
bad you hang out a bar can you not do
that at home by the way if there's a bar
he didn't say hello
he's by the way he's older than i am hey
dude let's go to another no he's 53. he
is yeah you're older than he is
go back to his respective faces well he
didn't let him have it
i feel like i look a little yeah you
look better yeah a little younger than
james bond well he looks you know he
looks like he looks about 60 there
doesn't do that i think just because he
looks older doesn't necessarily he means
that he looks worse yeah that's what i'm
saying those are mutually worse i'm just
saying he looks he looks much he looks
does he yeah
he looks smaller too right he was like
built
he's probably a little bit is he small
yeah i think he's just small built
really i thought he was a big guy but
look at those shoulders no before he was
bigger but now
as he ages it's got he's got a lot
smaller um
yeah i i just don't think that i
wouldn't i've never gone you know at the
bar
there's a bar here let's go to this gate
now i don't think so busted being in a
gay bar
you know what i'm saying like well on
bazi for those of you don't know is a
super welcome gay guy and former owner
of the palm restaurant he's too obscure
celebrities with michael grew in his
tick-tockers his husband also found ca
so he's got a [ __ ] ton of money
regardless if i run into daniel craig at
a gay bar i'm going to have to fight him
for an environment that's designed
specifically to make him uncomfortable
it's not fair head on a swivel bond
that's hilarious
that's funny he also said by comparison
craig says gay bars were chill and a
safe place to be where someone's
sexually sexuality didn't matter he also
revealed having an alternative motive i
could meet girls there because there
were a lot of girls there for exactly
same reason i was he branded me to pick
it up story after this [ __ ] storm and a
teacup
he's awesome
i like him i like yeah i see you in a
gay bar
i'm gay you're gay yeah yeah one of the
gay martyrs there's one reason if i see
you when you're doing poppers i'm like
all right
look at him how tall he is
yeah if you see me gabe are sweet gay
man what's a popper
so a popper is like a ammo nitrate or
something and it opens your your
butthole it kind of relaxes your rump so
if you're going to get crazy
somebody's probably five eight yeah
probably right he's 53.
great actor yeah
uh yeah
wait oh yeah we did there is a new tick
tock challenge where people are playing
kesha's song die young and there's a
part where there's a loud
thud that happens and people are now
kicking in doors to the beat of that
song and it's going viral amongst
college students what they're like going
up and down dorms or their apartment
buildings doing this i mean just the
wrong house you send texts or something
in my [ __ ] shop you can get shot
you kick down my door i'm gonna shoot
you man
they do it loud
yeah that's not good and then the very
last one shows somebody knock on the
door they try to break it down yeah
no they knock on it
they bang it it's good it's just good
fun
see this person knew
it looks like dorm rooms also that was a
lightsaber it's just a dorm [ __ ] yeah i
don't know
yeah yeah they're local it's not as
people's houses
it's like apartment college apartments
it's the lamest thing ever
kids are doing too much on tick-tock
you're trying to they're slapping
teachers everything's knocking down
doors
yeah yeah i saw that where you're
hitting a teacher i saw some like black
girl beat up this teacher it's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
colin powell died today oh yeah he did
from secretary of state
he's 84 years old he was 84 he also had
multiple myeloma which is a blood cancer
for a long time so not so much you know
the right's going to run with it because
he was also
vaccinate
yeah
but he's 84 and he had cancer you know
multiple myeloma is no joke it [ __ ]
with your immune system he was the beast
man oh yeah
yep
he had also parkinson's parkinson's oh
[ __ ] yeah that's a lot of people you
didn't look at
your body starts to break checklist yeah
stuff
shout out to colin powell yeah start as
an actress sorry not play
any good
yeah she was really good actually
okay
um
smash mouth the lead singer he is
actually retired now because he someone
recorded him put him on tick tock where
he was just you know slurring and saying
really bad stuff into the crowd he's not
in great shape but yeah but uh yeah so
yeah i'll play it first
i like when they say it's healthy yeah i
think this aren't great
dude
he's not sitting live at a local bureau
he just doesn't remember the lyrics when
i say this is the most chaotic show i've
ever seen in my entire life
i have no words at no point was this
sound balanced
is that what he looks like now yeah
unintelligible
there's more to it though i'll tell you
guys
[Music]
the guitar player has to sing it
i can't believe that's what he looks
like now
[Music]
so uh i guess his team is saying that he
he's suffering from mental stuff and
physical stuff ailments like he's been
really bad for a while oh so he
shouldn't even be yeah
so
that's who but his episode happened at
that time when they recorded and they
put on tick tock went viral so yeah i
think he had another freak out like not
too long ago too
yeah i mean he's they're saying it's
he's me he's like a mental thing and
also a physical thing i didn't know he's
still doing it yeah it's not a good
thing there was 14 people there yeah
so hey now you're in all the time he
couldn't
he was like you know usually there's a
one hit wonder he was like two or three
hit and that was kind of it right
something like that fly nickelback just
keeps powering through they have uh
walking on the sun or something like
that
yeah he'll be walking on us huh
i think that's smashmouth i think you're
right
well now it's this
yeah
tough all right it happened um
we were talking a lot in this
interesting yeah we're talking a lot in
this superman's son came out as bisexual
in the new comic i don't know if
superman had a son comics have really
gone a long way yeah also why do we need
their sexual orientation
i think that's happening a lot as you're
just saying all right
right in comics right i don't know like
you know robin robin came about as
bisexual oh yeah yeah
we knew that yeah
[Laughter]
i want to see how this fares
like i think boys gonna be like all
right well i'm not
okay
yeah three percent of the kids out there
that are gay or whatever it is are gonna
be like okay well yeah who are you
i guess they might feel better that they
black panther with uh african-american
kids like now they have a hero to look
up to so this is kind of like yeah my my
buddy my buddy's son is going to rhode
island school of design
really hard architecture school like art
school like the best and they have uh
it's a parent's weekend and they have
three events only for african americans
here's the problem
it's all white and asians are three
african-americans so they're going
through them there's only three and it's
like they're all like oh
okay and they're all so are you trying
to make them
trying to alienate so funny man this
stuff you know
yeah um so i have one thing to say about
that i remember when crazy rich asians
came out yeah you were stoked no no i
didn't watch it yet still oh he's a
hater i'm not a hater
here's my style
chinese it's chinese not koran there's a
big difference or indonesia how are you
gonna tell them
people say asian like why would a korean
have anything in common with that
chinese movie right it's like i mean i
understand it's asian but i mean so have
you guys watched it or not no i haven't
watched no okay so was it good was it
really good or is it okay it's just a
rum it's just a romantic film that's a
romantic comedy just romantic film which
is the first night of it it was the
first no did you did you see mark norman
you seen martin horton's tweet about oh
there's not enough diversity in this
movie
that is funny
it's so good so she's such a beast
there was one oh yeah what am i gonna
say yeah yeah i was gonna say something
about squid game but no never mind but
uh so when when crazy rich angels came
out
i had a bunch of different asian people
hit me up saying like we have to make
sure we pack the theaters to do this
this is this i'm like did you guys watch
the movie yet no but we have to because
it's gonna you know yeah it'll put us in
the spotlight yeah so for me i'm like it
did i'll do it once
people say it's awesome you know yeah
like i got to watch the movie just yeah
it's just
good movies
yeah it made a fortune i'd rather a
movie be good just because it's good i
want to watch it i don't care black
white mexican asian if it's good i don't
give a [ __ ] however so i know people
that work in you know
in production and entertainment so one
girl that i know that we know
uh she always sends her screenplays to
different companies after crazy rich
asians was that big she said she never
had more people call her back oh wow for
that so there's something there there
really is something there for sure yeah
that's cool yeah once it's a hit people
are like oh what else does the crane
like squid games they're looking for
like weird games right now oh yeah yeah
it's 100 yeah they're just [ __ ]
combing the korean seas for us have you
started it yet no
it's only nine episodes
yes
you're finishing it you guys just have
to stop talking about it as soon as you
stop
watching it's a lot
to shut up about it so brendan will
watch it all right no more man davidoff
did this for the long time with the
iphone he's like man i'm not getting it
i'm like you're you've got a flip phone
you [ __ ] idiot and then finally he
gets her iphone oh my god you know this
thing is uh i'm like
don't talk to me about it
i've i've heard mick's uh results on it
on what on squid uh
i don't know
who has said that they're [ __ ] idiots
you said anything negative about that
they're not negative if you come in
if you come in two years later and you
do this you go this great game is good
you're gonna go like this
i'm gonna don't think about i jack off
game of thrones
but go ahead and watch that it's it's
really go ahead so you can just not talk
about it in two years
just watch it bro it's not a competition
do you mind yeah and now you guys are
forcing me i don't want to do
i'm on it three of the crown i started
that i have one more i have two more
seasons three and four left after that
then i'll jump to squid game sweet but
you season three came out so squid games
gets put on the back
the crown huh you like the costumes in
the english accent
i don't give a [ __ ] about the crowd i
know i don't
know game of thrones yeah game of
thrones is fake yeah well it's but it's
based off obviously there's no dragons
but the family the family all the family
fighting is based off that's real [ __ ]
yeah it is and squid games could be
happening somewhere in north korea right
now yeah now yeah it could
yeah you guys are driving me back back
back just watch the [ __ ] show dude
give it a whirl god yellowstone starts
opening no i'm bad
and there's subtitles and yeah oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] doesn't seem too
i cannot tell you how incredible this is
and also it's not like uh like north
korea or there's parts of it like that
but it's more like illuminati type of
stuff yeah yeah if there's really really
powerful rich people around yeah this
can happen something like this that's
true well it's it's really human where
you go you do believe it and then you'll
see yourself in some of the characters
too you'll as much as you want to judge
people you're like oh my god free you
were in that position
when brian talks about it it makes me
not want to win
because if you say one more time if one
i'm telling you
i'll never watch it i hear one the way
it's shot you're not a director
shut up brian around you're the most
annoying has been around this production
i know a couple yeah but everything
one more time someone goes i know i'm
not gonna say that well the way it shot
in action is amazing but i will say this
the like just the psychology yes yeah
you're going to love that psychology the
way you after episode one where you go
[ __ ] when they did the partner thing
that [ __ ] me up all right no more so
sick
no spoilers no spoilers
i'll get around [ __ ] me up
i have too many shows so annoying i
think you would like it as a father
because there is a storyline about a
father yes his daughter that i think you
would relate
no we're not gonna say anything the
daughter doesn't die i'll tell you yeah
that much enough i don't watch any of
that you don't watch anything where kids
die so there's that
yeah
all right all right i got a bunch of
[ __ ] i get doing it
but you got to watch it before people
ruin it for you
you don't want to is it
like spoilers
it's okay there are no squishies
spoilers on world star you know yeah i
hope you only see it off world star what
people people always say squid games it
is the actual title squid game oh yeah
oh there's not that's not that that's a
big deal but yeah it's quick
everybody gonna be rocking that costume
this year though
oh you got oh [ __ ] i got one from try
some pictures of me and then uh butters
is going to be a squid that's so funny
okay well hooters i guess had a
not necessarily mandate they said
they're going to change the shorts to a
different design well because shorter
shots focus on tits
like booties right so i'll show you what
is the thing this is what it looks like
now
do i tell you right now hooters makes a
nice wing
they're not a bad wing they're not bad
at all anything else on that menu though
trash let me see this yeah you don't
want to those are the new shorts those
are the ones
anyways i'll show you the pictures here
because i can't use the audio that's
tough yeah
so this is the new shorts
which is basically like underwear yeah
basically like booty shorts hey here's
the thing don't work at hooters
that is true you don't have to worry
here's what you can do go work at tgi
friday go be a bird at red robin yeah oh
those are but they're so high yeah
they're so tight definitely pregnant tip
more than that's their favorite and
she's gonna get into mine
if she's giving me wings
[Applause]
someone mentioned that waitress
mentioned that she got more tips because
of these shorts yeah that's why they're
doing it yeah but now they got backlash
so they're not they're not necessarily
mandating anymore you can wear the other
shorts or these
are strange right because you're not
going to go there with your like kids
and you know it's like you know you do
feel kind of dirty when you're in there
it's like a strip club with wings yeah
if you oppose that other one tilted
kills
that one's like dude
that one looks very uncomfortable for
the girls sometimes i don't care about
that don't worry then you know it's like
a stripper completely get their tits out
yeah you signed up for it man well it is
called whoever earned cats it's called
hooters yeah fortune because they're
tense yeah tits and wings and these the
twin peaks is what it's called now where
they hire hot chicks there's one in
colorado there's one
oh yeah twin pizzas like that pizza
really big tits give her a tilted kilt
you never heard of twin peaks with big
tits big bear no
big tits big bear that's one thing
peaks that's twin peaks wow now you
can't go to twin peaks and then expect
to get higher when he got [ __ ] bee
stings for tits you feel me
you feel maybe
i don't know dude you're crying come on
dude
see if tilted kill stuff well it's like
if i look at me it does well it's like
if i applied for a job at trunks and i
had a little dick you're like dude your
[ __ ] just got big enough and i assume
right
that trunks trunks
they still exist just trunks and you
just got to have a bed yeah just a dog
yeah you have that trunk index finger
you're gonna have that trunk dude yep
and just your dick is going
yeah i want to start a coffee shop
called trumps strong it's all guys
it's dark gross dark men trunks trunks
yeah
now i'm not hiring if you got a little
dick dude that's the deal
trunks nobody how fast we get shut down
i don't think anybody go there just
seeing dudes with their in west
hollywood i've been beaten yeah [ __ ]
smelly other men due to ice
all right
but the vietnamese have it down the cop
the coffee shops
[Music]
they have the craziest ones was it toes
java something java hut do you know java
feet i don't remember espresso on toast
i tried getting cats to go to a coffee
shop with me in the oc all asians
all coffee oh coffee all the tits baby
feet wet mouths
and we have a boom boom room in the back
look at that jesus yeah they do it right
yeah wow look at that there's our boy
oh [ __ ]
and that's a very that's a super popular
one too cafe lou oh yeah cafe little
it's poppin we have one back home called
bikini beans
we're all they're all i don't know
rampage i guess he was sparring with
dylan white it wasn't fighting him never
mind
never mind yeah but they're probably the
most kind of feeling did you get what
kind of food is it
vietnamese food oh lord have mercy it's
strong super strong coffee super strong
strong asses flat ass dude you love
strongest coffee strongest strong coffee
and flat asses
that's what we'd be known for yeah big
tits flat asses a lot of uh white girls
and mexican girls who work at asian
coffee shops oh really yeah bring that
one up there just so they even it out
make sure everything is good right there
i want to make sure everything's okay
yeah dude you getting a nice one a nice
[ __ ] americano from her i mean you
know that's all i'm asking you you're
tipping well jesus
these are the vietnamese coffee shops
yes yeah this is what we do this is an
orange county this one that cat owns
dude there's one in orange county in
every like one mile radius did you say
are you serious yeah westminster i've
never been to you you're a family owned
one of them no i'm just kidding it says
yeah i've had on to uh owned two three
coffee shops you don't know let me ask
you this this is what i was gonna do if
i didn't go off to college actually she
mentioned this before yeah that's
fantastic because this is like what my
family does it's seen as normal sure and
i'd love to talk to your family about it
but the thing is so if i go there's a
young lady with a blowout ass and i have
hard cold cash
coffee yeah i'm all filled with energy
now okay what do we do
to you and the discretion of the girls
there are girls who will do extra stuff
on the side interesting a lot of these
girls get their boyfriends at the cafe
shop uh no usually you guys just hang
out afterwards somewhere else oh oh it's
a holler people do give numbers out
there's not a boom
in the dark caffeine is running through
your body no dude i like my espresso in
the dark that's all you're doing you
just want some espresso in the dark
a man can't just relax dude i can't get
a dark roast on a dick size this day and
age that's all
[ __ ]
what world are we living in what america
are we living in the caffeine
you went too much i knew i did yep you
finally went up me i just wanted to wow
sorry everybody anyways there's a lot of
beautiful girls that's fantastic she's
adorable
yeah cute
police officers in orange county love
vietnamese coffee shops of course i love
them i would love to go yeah do you get
a nice french press that takes a little
time so i can talk right you don't take
a little french press i can take my time
that's all well needs to steep that's
all what's steeping uh-huh i got cash
yeah you do i want coffee right now
actually
what dick's sucking a steep isn't that
fun
dick's not going to steam
all right jim
um so tom cruise has been brian's
disgusting by the way
in the news lately because his face has
changed just remember like that you know
cat bro zac efron before yeah his face
changed
apparently tom cruise's face has changed
that's him at a game
uh that's uh fillers
that's so yeah there's even like a
plastic surgeon that said that it's
probably fillers and some other stuff in
there you know you can do and i'm
looking at getting it myself you know
you can get fat taken out of your face
oh yeah the uh bugle fat it'll give you
the like uh look right here
you might be holding water bubba i don't
know if that's yeah i know they're gonna
suck all that out
now you've got your lids done you're
gonna judge me
i just don't want you to do that right
now just take it easy first time take it
a little bit yeah take it easy let's
let's do a skinny face fat body yeah
let's wait a little bit let's keep our
face puffy and your face is a little
puffy it always is a little bit like
it's salt
you got a lot of stuff running through
your veins so maybe that can be part of
it
this guy salty last night that looks
that sometimes can be medication or
something he looks too yeah reaction is
something terrifying he doesn't look
great oh my god oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you get
older my cheeks that big no they're not
right no he's you know he's an older man
yeah yeah yeah but why is your face how
does he know 50 something he looks
insane 60 almost keep going keep going
down yeah
it's all right
dime of all time that's interview with
the van yeah
yellow teeth whatever yeah get his teeth
together
that's him when he's jumping on the
couch at oprah
yeah that's him with the biebs cut 2010
so this kind of looks similar to that
though teeth are a little strange dude i
have a friend who worked with him met
with him on a project he's so paranoid
about where people uh are going to find
out where he lives
she drove with her team and his team to
meet with him at this house in beverly
hills she gets there and she's like
it's weird it's like super empty it
doesn't feel like somebody lives here
but he has pictures on the wall
and uh she goes hey is okay if i get
something to drink he's like yeah she's
like where's the drinks oh
uh he didn't know like you tell it was a
staged house but he owns it yeah but he
doesn't want people he's so paranoid
it's down the street his real house down
the street he takes meetings at this
fake house
what a baller that's a lot to call your
agent hey i need a fake house well he
doesn't live in l.a anymore now we moved
to florida come out here he's also
honestly originally from kentucky
uh i think i thought he was new jersey
originally or something but he uh he's
always he's always um he's such a beast
town
syracuse
you said kentucky way off and you didn't
say anything about it
because i think i think there's
something with him in kentucky he never
met his dad or his dad took off when he
was young and so i think he i'm sure i'm
sure they're wikipedia i think he's
trying to cruise new jersey man i think
he grew up in jersey
for well by the way he's been working
since he was oh he attended high school
in louisville
there you go
damn you can kind of claim them i guess
yeah all right
wow
five things what's the five things
intense kid
i i worked with them or did a reading
with them and then had some i've had
some long conversations with the nicest
[ __ ] dude in the world oh he's such a
such a good guy man
i love that he's such a beast doing his
own stunt [ __ ] blown his [ __ ] out all
the time i spent oh i did a reading with
todd phillips and for this this movie
called the men i had all my scenes with
him it's pretty cool there's my six of
us in the room i spent two hours with
him what was fascinating is that the
[ __ ] guy wanted to hear from every
one of us
he wanted to hear from every one of us
about what we thought of the script what
could change about it i've never seen
anybody more intense in my life well
that's why he's so successful oh he's
been doing who's this
tommy cruz tom cruise and then i saw him
at a party and talked to him he was
saying he said denzel washington he said
a couple of names
he was so [ __ ] nice and i remember
and i remember saying to other people i
was like what's he like and i know
people have worked with him for for a
long time i know somebody did a movie in
six months every scene with him and said
he's the nicest man in the world
everybody i know says yeah i think the
knockout is just the scientology [ __ ]
like put a weird light on it i also
think he's probably a weird guy i think
also he
somehow yeah weird
weird fishbowl that he's in and he's the
most i mean
tell us about real movie stars tom
cruise leonardo dicaprio denzel
washington that's a out of the three
like he's different in that he's had
trouble having a family and having a
relationship and i don't know where
that's what that is about
you know could be other things could be
his kids and then he was married to home
girls yeah i guess he doesn't really
katie holmes i guess katie holmes took
those kids though she kind of like
called him nicole
yeah yeah i don't know how much of a
relationship he has with those children
i think he's on [ __ ] set he's gone
all the time yeah
it's a weird thing to be yeah yeah like
are there any pictures made to the games
yeah at that dodgers game that he was
with his kid oh okay i hope so i mean
you know
but i i i've heard nothing but good
things about him i don't know you gotta
respect them oh yeah i don't know about
as a father but
yeah they adopted kids right the
adoption
yeah
that's the other thing is that yeah
is that his biological child or is that
no i think they adopted him yeah he's
cute madonna adopted a
black kid i think he just had a birthday
well why wouldn't he have his own kids
he did he did and they adopted okay
i grew up yeah he's a mystery
he kind of looks like him even though
he's adopted yeah
or did tom have sex with a black girl
he looks awfully like him doesn't he
yeah he didn't he yeah i think that's a
job from ethiopia originally or
something that's cool all right what
else you got to
uh real quick on that so
my old boss
she was big in scientology i found out
later after i got the job hell yeah and
uh so she would take care of his kids
every now and then oh wow so and also
she said because you know i didn't know
that she was part of scientology until
later i googled later but then uh she
said everyone that meets tom he kind of
remembers everyone's name which is
impressive right and it makes you feel
really close to the map yeah you feel
important but he's a super good person
good dad it's just and i heard also
scientology is like a
a weird way to get into
acting and like in movies yeah there's a
connection there yeah i don't know about
anybody it never really was actually he
used to well i'm john travolta tom
cruise that's the christian christian
alley i have actually yeah i have a lot
of experience with it a lot because
remember you wouldn't do scientology if
they're like okay do you get roles you
can be the next batman if you're not
converting well i mean i i've done those
weird cups that i like remember i was in
in going clear the acting class that's
featured in that i was in that class for
13 years
you're scientology i also have done
benefits at the scientology center i
also did fat actions with christie alley
she was a scientologist we shot in the
scientology center we stayed at at their
facilities they were trying to convert
you and and
and oh by the way everybody that worked
on that said everyone including the
actors were all scientologists including
giant
did they ever try converting you you
know
they never did the answer is no ain't
that and that makes me feel bad
you weren't talented enough i wasn't
talented enough because they only go
after like the top echelon people they
they i was like hey i'm interested in it
we'll send you literature
no i'm in this hey guys about me i'm
here right now we're good yeah no we're
all full dude yeah
i saw a lot of i saw a lot of people
come and go so a lot actors join up in
the hopes that
something with this home girl from king
of queens
oh yeah romney i knew her she out of
them yeah she wouldn't harm the pain on
them oh yeah she's the right one yeah
and rogan and she had her own show
she was she heard inside and tell like
they disciplined like yeah you got to
wash the floors with like a toothbrush
and [ __ ] like it's super super well
david miscavige i mean he was dude again
it's like brendan you're the next batman
i'm [ __ ] taking that two tooth
depression doing work
cry me a river dude
i'm an actor if i'm in mission
impossible 19. yeah yeah you're treated
very well there
if you're if you're if you're famous you
have yeah yeah they control a lot of
stuff though
they do think that they forced tom and
homegirl that you mentioned cody homes
yeah to get married like that was all
scientology like this what you're gonna
do and i mean you see katie holmes she
had to escape she literally just had to
get out her dad i guess has got money
and it's like a cult yeah they took the
kids and her and her brother's off
monster too
is he did you [ __ ] kitty homes
really you know what i'm thinking
somebody else uh you know jake
gyllenhaal his sister
oh maggie yeah jake gyllenhaal maggie
jillian
from uh batman returns
bad casting if you ask me what else you
get oh there's a new batman trailer out
have you seen that
i heard it's the most violent one i like
that it looks like that one i heard
patent oswald it's the most violent
batman yeah
what'd i say oswald
of here you've been swearing and missing
here with these
he has the boys i like that you don't
even move he doesn't he's like that was
oh he was a penguin yeah that's what i
assumed when you said pacquiao penguin
oh you killed the penguin yeah you would
kill the people
the penguin he's the nicest guy in the
world pat and he's such a sweetie
he was also on king of queens he was
great but he was like yeah he was on
king and queens he was great yeah and i
still even though he's super liberal i'm
sorry i still like him such a nice guy
great right such a beast coming [ __ ]
great
boy and he i like when he goes that ted
cruz it's hilarious on twitter they
light each other up yeah yeah oh you do
yeah
is that it oh one more so this guy is a
tom we were on tom cruise so this guy's
a tom groot tom cruise impressionist
only tricked bieber right bieber thought
it was tom cruise i think so the the
thing with deep fakes they're so
freaking good right now i guarantee you
won't even know the difference do the
bieber one
i don't know if this is actually bieber
no that's bieber he thinks he's what
[Music]
instagram
is that him as bieber
that's the thing i don't know
no no i think that's justin bieber there
you go yeah so let's just be recovering
tom cruise covering this guy covering
okay
so let's go to him
can you tell that this is a defense
[ __ ] it's so good now oh my god yeah 60
minutes did the whole thing yeah exactly
wait that's not good no it's not tom
cruise it's it's a computer generated
but he sounds just like
i don't give a damn cause nobody listens
when they're on instagram
they just click and like you can tell a
little something's off yeah i don't know
when it moves
but it's so hard it's so scary
his mannerisms like well now we can't
trust video i know you
[Music]
two thousand can't
this guy's talking let me refresh and
see how
if it's different
oh no it's the same how does this one
is it a real
i don't know i don't know go back chin
let me see one more
scroll down
he has one rogan talked about him i
guess i'll go check this out it's not
talk
impression time this is a five second
impression of a snapping turtle coming
out of a show
they mess up my hair
nope
how crazy is that so because
it's like very good though
that's a good question i'm not sure most
i would say most likely then i like to
treat myself
and uh it's good because discipline
oh
[Applause]
oh my god
it's just like
i think there's bubble gum inside though
[Applause]
that's incredible that's [ __ ] crazy
and crap how come nobody ever told me
there's bubble gum
incredible
oh yeah so many people are gonna get
catfished like this i know oh yeah the
horse though he's so good and then it
matches so well yeah he's doing like
it's subtle funny yeah weird crazy man
but the guy kind of looks like yeah he
definitely kind of looks like him that's
why it helps for sure the more you look
like someone like the shape of the head
and [ __ ] i mean he looks just like
just like feel like but it's also is
uh they do that though that's funny he
looks like that manner
have you seen the robin the guy that
looks like robin williams that does it
no oh yeah yeah that guy that guy's
pretty good too robin robin williams in
person he's like really [ __ ] good at
it but he looks like him he's he's not
yeah in the face technology he actually
looks like him
yeah he's not using a deep fake
well dreams are a beautiful aspect no
that's not right
he's he's not a deep fake oh it's not a
deep fake no he like really looks like a
impressionist yeah robin williams care
about impression
impersonator yep
this guy
trying yeah do that
you have to allow ads to play the videos
oh mm-hmm they don't let you skip it no
you don't spend much time on youtube
though
chapelle said who is this
culture in fact it happens when you're
at night and you close your eyes and all
kinds of images happen and it's really
bizarre well let's try this one well it
depends on all you ask if you ask
cinderella she might sing it to you and
say a dream is a wish your heart robin
john's not dead i was with him last
night
yeah you do know he was with john
belushi the night oh was he really yeah
so did you say de niro daenerys with him
too they got they did drugs and they
were like all right we're getting out
here and left oh yeah
is that the chateau
marmont
all right that's it man well uh
liberty township this weekend guys
cincinnati liberty township friday
saturday back on a plane that kind of
plane ohio kids ohio ohio and then i got
uh oh god i got no uh yeah over fourth
and fifth at the brea improv and then i
got [ __ ] um
i got yeah uh november 11th to the 14th
i'll be in off the hook comedy club in
naples get you tickets boom boom all
right kids uh
dallas is november 11th through the 13th
one special ass weekend for your boy
with chappelle backflip lacy and david
lucas dallas texas november 11th through
the 13th that is almost sold out we have
to add some shows so get your tickets
right now addison improv in dallas texas
we will be doing a secret uh pop-up uh
two shows thursday friday november
fourth and fifth in la i'll have info
for you guys we'll run the 30 minute
special the week before i shoot in
dallas that's november 4th and 5th in la
stay tuned to my social media because
we'll announce that those [ __ ] are
going to sell out so get them while you
can but i will announce it all right all
right october 28th through the 29th or
through the 30th i'll be in washington
dc at the dc comedy loft november 17th
tacoma comedy club november 18th spokane
comedy club and december 1st san jose
improv
yay
yeah
yeah love you guys
love you guys